hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on just seeing how your
weeks going you know a lot of people
when they podcast for one week they
don't [ __ ] think about their
listeners for the rest of the week but
you know what not this guy I think about
you I think I think about you Oh was
that that was [ __ ] constant roses oh
right all that [ __ ] falsetto singing
back then Oh everyone will go nuts and
they would have their [ __ ] light is
up in the air already right out of the
gate you can say cheap bill you have a
lot more energy than you've had lately
what's going on with you well Ted what's
going on today's the the last day we're
rapping on the movie front runner
starring a Hugh Jackman directed by
Jason Reitman this is the last day I'm
very excited because I think it's gonna
be a great movie and I also get to go
home and see my family is that my
daughter oh very quiet got a quick
little run in New York and then I'm done
I'm just done for the rest of year other
than the times I go to New Mexico in
Arizona
okay I mean I still am a traveling
comedian I still am a plate spinner but
I'm pretty much home till like the end
of January which is awesome so I will be
spending that time with my family and
going and punching up and editing some
of the first cuts of season 3 of EFT is
for family that's what I'm doing you
know getting into the Thanksgiving
spirit Thanksgiving often-overlooked
you know the second Halloween comes
along everybody goes oh [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] Christmas season but people
forget that there's a holiday you know
the holiday you don't have to have many
gifts all you got to do is show up you
show up the Wednesday before
Thanksgiving you go down to the local
bar and a lot of the chicks that you
were too afraid to talk to are gonna be
down there a lot of the chicks that were
afraid to be talked to it gonna be down
there everybody's looking for some
sentimental sex right well some what if
encounters sorry I don't mean to go all
harvey weinstein here all of that was
consensual
all right Jesus Christ it's just one
accusation after another finally these
all these famous people are starting to
go like yeah I have no idea that is or
yeah I don't I don't know I don't
remember that you know which I was
surprised right out of the gate they
didn't do I'm not condoning their
behavior I'm just saying legal advice
years later after the jizz has
disappeared off you throughout the plant
that you [ __ ] came on you think that
these people would go into denial like
that [ __ ] Supreme Court judge going I
I don't know what you're talking about I
didn't do that I just went back to my
study and I was reading on how to become
a better person they're slowly starting
to do that but anyways why bill why on
such a glorious holiday month would you
bring up such a scandal there should be
like you know what you should start
doing like a like you know you have like
a Deadpool they should do you should do
like a pool now we just [ __ ] you try
to bet on who's the next person I came
is same thing cuz it's not funny to
[ __ ] accuse somebody that [ __ ] trying
to think of anybody who I know now I
ain't gonna [ __ ] do that but let's
get let's go with something positive I
went to the best music store I've been
to an IKE since I don't know went with
the best commercial on YouTube which I'm
gonna post off of the Monday morning
podcast Twitter account Portman's music
store in Savannah Georgia is hands-down
the best music store I've been to what
do you want huh you want a French horn
they got it
you want to bassoon they got it you want
to didgeridoo they got
are you an old man and you got to read
some charts and you [ __ ] Isaac gone
they actually sell readers up at the up
at the counter a little you know those
glasses when you don't want to just
waste your money getting a prescription
you just go out and you get the readers
you just try some on and I think look
good things that go right they sold
those I went to over there just to get
some drumsticks and next thing you know
I'm actually thinking of buying a
trumpet I always love the trumpet I
always loved the power of that [ __ ]
instrument you know and I actually
looked at one for the first time and had
this guy explained to me the whole way
that it worked and I was thinking about
it and then fortunately I called my wife
and she goes she's not buying a [ __ ]
trumpet why do wives always do that they
always you know I'm not saying that she
was wrong but they always do you want
you're not doing that you're not buying
a boat you can do it you're not putting
the speed bag up on the side of the
house what you know it doesn't rain that
much there's a tree over it honey we're
not doing that right they always do that
to us but when can we always ever sit
there looking and be like like white
honey you're not buying another pair of
shoes
you're not buying anymore throat pillows
you already can't sit on the [ __ ]
couch there's too many I'm not yelling
now I am yes but I wasn't oh you know
what [ __ ] you yeah yeah [ __ ] you fine I
don't give a [ __ ] I didn't want to go
there anyway so why do you have to ruin
the weekend alright that's the way it
goes why can't we do that what you know
we should just we got to figure out what
they do obviously we can't start crying
you know and they'll [ __ ] send us to
some goddamn home I'm gonna do that next
time I'm buying a trumpet you're not
buying a trumpet don't be big to me
[Laughter]
she was right in another life you know
come on man the trumpet with the plunger
on the end getting that Jimi Hendrix
wah-wah sound
maybe that's why that's probably where
he got it from right he probably wanted
to have that sound in the guitar cuz he
was probably listening to somebody
playing a [ __ ] horn I don't know what
but I always loved the trumpet and the
trombone and the saxophones kind of
hacky too like that's like liking guitar
everybody likes [ __ ] guitar everybody
like somebody comes to horns everybody
likes to saxophone right the [ __ ]
trombones this [ __ ] right the trumpet
never listen to a big band and those
four trumpet players show up they
[ __ ] so you know they stand up and
they start playing their little section
they almost knock you out of your seat I
don't know man they were [ __ ] cool
and they were expensive as [ __ ] like the
cheapest one was like that they had
there was like six seven eight hundred
bucks and one of the parents are always
[ __ ] freaking out when that kid stops
playing the trumpet it's like dude you
know I could have bought a new riding
mower do you know what stopped me from
playing the trumpet other than just poor
you know musical gifts was I didn't want
to get that [ __ ] up lip and then the
guy behind the counter told me he said
oh that's just poor technique that's
just from press and probably your
embouchure or whatever the [ __ ] they
call it is wrong so to make up for it
you got to press it against your lips
and then you get like that that you know
you know you look like somebody beat you
with a trumpet rather than you play one
right and he's like now you just want to
be relaxed you want to be relaxed since
everything is that in life you know what
I mean you want to be relaxed you want
to hit a home run don't try and kill it
just swing through the [ __ ] zone let
the bat meet the ball there it goes
right in a Little League field for me
professional guys they could hit it out
of Fenway Park
right stop trying to kill it golf you
want to drive it a bunch of yards there
right you want to show off you're on the
first tee you have you all the [ __ ]
dude standing behind you one woman and
somebody of color so nobody can say your
[ __ ] membership is racist right you
fly them in and everybody's standing
there watching you you're waiting to tee
off right you're feeling the sweat going
down the back of your ball bag and what
do you do you grip it a little tighter
you [ __ ] go back like John Daly you
swing outside your zone and you [ __ ]
go through your little hat but the
pom-pom falls off you fall on your ass
your white slacks get a grass stain on
them and wait it's a ball go huh [ __ ]
record shades off the lady's teeth and
everybody Snickers everybody Snickers
then you're in a bad mood you have a bad
round and then you [ __ ] come home you
throw your clubs down right and then
your wife comes out and wants you to
emot-- the next thing you know you got
your hands around a throat right her
eyes are rolling back she's making dents
on the [ __ ] what you mean you know how
it ends right you know how it ends it
ends with the trip to Home Depot you're
buying a pickaxe and some sort of lime
and all you had to do all you had to do
was just relax go up this smile and wave
at all your so-called friends that you
know a rootin against you you know stay
within yourself be nice and relaxed
don't give a [ __ ] let the face meet the
[ __ ] ball there it goes right down
the goddamn fairway but no you tried to
kill it and when it end up happening an
innocent woman died right and how you
gonna get caught huh because of the back
of her head think the imprints gonna be
on the hood of the car they come over
there to dust it right and then they'll
still be able to tell it's the perfect
shape of her skull with the little
little ponytail you know and then you
just sit there that's when you break
down on the on the [ __ ] stand like on
one of those classic Ironside all right
it was me remember those old stupid
court dramas the early days of movies
and television [ __ ] all you had to do
was just asks the person the defender
a bunch of quick questions you know they
just be like you went golfing that day
didn't you yeah what about it
everyone was watching weren't they they
were watching in you squeeze the club
fluoride no I didn't get on you keep he
went home and he tells you I alright I
did it she never believed in my golf
game she right they always did that and
then they always shook women and slapped
them you know and that was the backbone
a Hollywood and for some [ __ ] reason
67 years later everybody surprised that
people are running around grabbing
people by their privates and finishing
on a plant anyways I guess was it the
midterm election I don't know what
happened all I know is I was down in the
sets and somebody said hey it's a good
good day for Democrats and I was just
like what do you mean he goes yesterday
man he said the Democrats Democrats
[ __ ] killed it yesterday and my first
thought was well did they elect good
Democrats you know what I mean I don't
like how people look at politics the way
they look at their sports team you know
what I mean where like if it's a bad
call as long as it goes in the favor of
your team you like god that was fine you
know like Hillary supporters doing that
stupid Thank You Hillary which was
probably started by her people I don't
understand what people on the Left are
doing still trying to push her over the
top at some point you just got to admit
you wasted a draft pick and you got to
move on to somebody else I've never seen
somebody just keep coming back like
[ __ ] Freddy Krueger since probably
Richard Nixon that has to be her spirit
animal my favorite my [ __ ] why don't
I just say favorite that's the thing I
hate the most people say so-and-so is my
spirit animal
we [ __ ] eleven you got a pen pal -
yeah like if I was her I would just I
would look I would look at Richard Nixon
and be like okay this guy lost you know
one on the radio lost on TV he was
sitting there you know sitting there
like how you normally sit right he's got
sweater in his upper lip
JFK comes in all tanned up he's got his
legs crossed like he's doing panel on
the [ __ ] Tonight Show you know all
the women are watching going off I had
to [ __ ] a political dick that would be
the dick right so everybody [ __ ]
votes you know thinks that he won on TV
Nixon loses the election and then he
lost the governor's race in California
and literally was out of politics and
not eight years later Oh tricky dick
came back and won the [ __ ] White
House I think that's what Hillary's
trying to do but just watching everybody
on the left just ignoring completely
turning a [ __ ] blind eye to the fact
that Bernie Sanders got more votes and
that they admitted it in court the
Democratic National Party colluded with
her campaign to make her the [ __ ]
representative I mean can you give me a
[ __ ] break she's [ __ ] sitting
there bitching about the electoral
college I don't get it
I get if you're you're a woman and you
want a woman to be President but you
know can you pick a good one can we
start with that I mean how much more
corrupt can I don't know I just don't
get it
people's and being enamored with either
the bushes or the Clintons i I've had
enough with them I want a new last name
lying to me is that asking too much but
so anyway so I checked out some of those
elections and I'm weighing over my head
here but I just saw these weird
headlines like congratulations
such-and-such state you elected the
first transgendered person way to go
Vermont a way to go New Jersey
you elected the first Muslim whatever
that's a Sikh guy whatever I don't know
how to say that whatever there was
nothing in there that you elected
somebody who was qualified that's gonna
do a great [ __ ] job who happens to be
Polynesian or whatever I don't
understand they way it read the exact
same well that's like that's like how
white supremists you know they vote
strictly by you know race or whatever
like that doesn't make any sense
like can we just vote for people who are
good who actually have demonstrated that
they cannot be swayed by money and
they're actually gonna do what's going
to be good for the environment that's
going to be good for for poor people
middle-class people that's going to be
good for this country don't just [ __ ]
vote for somebody because of their
genitalia or or you know I mean I don't
get I don't get it this whole [ __ ]
idea that that sociopaths selfish people
liars are only white male heterosexuals
and that only they are susceptible to
being weak when they get positions of
power is is not a good road to go down
is the only thing I'm gonna say you got
it I don't know how you figure out what
the [ __ ] somebody's gonna do but like to
just be excited that somebody got in
there because of their sex other race is
is a very short-sighted way to look at
it you got to look at what the [ __ ] they
did is all I'm saying and I did not see
that in the headline I just thought oh
good this person's in there you know but
I feel like that's how we try to fix
[ __ ] like oh my god there was eight
years of Democrats [ __ ] this let's do
let's let's vote all Republican oh wait
a minute that doesn't work let's go all
Democrat that's what we just keep [ __ ]
doing and now we're gonna do that I
think on a row a a what do you call
gender and a race thing is what they're
gonna do and it's gonna be [ __ ] I'm
telling you you're gonna see the exact
same scandals
I did not have sex with that woman you
wait I want to see how this plays out
when they get in there right when the
non-white E's get in there and they got
their own private [ __ ] subway
you know everybody's eating [ __ ]
Lobster you know and it's all just
sitting there dangling you know you want
to be present hey buddy you want to be
President right and they got to get in
bed with all of these evil [ __ ]
corporations and then when they get in
there they got to do what those
corporations won right they got to do
what the [ __ ] they want and then if they
do then you end up like like Obama like
Bush like Clinton like all of these
[ __ ] people after their president
then you go on the [ __ ] bribe money
tour going out air-quote giving speeches
right why are you still giving speeches
you're not president anymore you don't I
mean it's Dan Marino walking around with
the football still throwing passes he's
retired what the [ __ ] you all you're
collect yeah Obama right now is on tour
69 million dollar tour giving speeches
let's say the guy doesn't give a good
speech but 69 million in one year a [ __ ]
out of here the [ __ ] out of here who's
he gonna go talk to huh who's he talking
to Joe Sixpack
I don't think so I know that was a very
bleak way of looking at it but there's
something positive in there I think we
need as as everybody represented
obviously in government but you got to
make sure that you're not just voting
you know just to get a woman in there or
something you got to make sure they're
good and that is that is my problem with
the Clintons I just think that they're
just [ __ ] there like I don't you know
what they are they just soulless [ __ ]
people there's got to be somebody better
than her all right but you know
Democrats if you want to hang your head
around somebody what Mike Dukakis is
[ __ ] charisma who
is comfortable in his own her own skin
is Al Gore to [ __ ] loses they can't
say hello to people lost the election
have you ever heard me talk politics as
much in your life would you think
someone who doesn't watch Fox News or
CNN or MSNBC or anything else who kind
of just gets his news from overhearing
one comment from somebody on a set while
doing eight lines in a movie anyway so
let's get back into my wheelhouse all
right whatever this is the podcast I
[ __ ] talk about what I want I talked
about buying a trumpet and I'm talking
about you know be funny if a woman gets
into office like like what is she gonna
like how is she gonna give it to you
know she gonna get like a bunch of
[ __ ] but like j.crew like boy toys
running around the White House who knows
I don't know what they're gonna do
she probably go like that that Ferdinand
Marcos chick there who had like [ __ ]
50,000 [ __ ] shoes that's what it is
guys are into like [ __ ] the we're
animals right ladies are into stuff
maybe that's what it is
they'll blow the entire defense budget
on like brooches or some [ __ ] alright
this is some of the dumbest [ __ ] I've
ever said I hope it makes you feel
better about yourself alright Oh last
day of the shoot 84 days sober I did it
alright
I booked this thing I was a fat booze
bag
I stopped [ __ ] drinking I did it so
can you
and so I'm a little nervous there cuz
now the shoot ends tonight and so now
what do I do is this weird thing where I
don't want to I don't want to end my
streak I think I can get at least a
hundred days then I'm going through
Thanksgiving without drinking but is
that a bad thing you know what I mean
rather than you know drinking and kind
of forget in half the meal and then
waking up at 4:00 in the morning with
the TV still on
you know sweating my ass off and some
Thanksgiving sweater being like what the
[ __ ] where is everybody did I say good
night you know
stay he go downstairs you talk to your
wife you're like good morning she just
looks at you and keeps brushing her
teeth
you like how [ __ ] did you have fun
yesterday she stops brushing your teeth
slams a hand down on the counter spits
out and then [ __ ] turns to sink on
turns it off and it turns hearing like
how [ __ ] what did I do
what did I say I don't want to do that
I'll do that the day after right when I
watch all those rivalry games Harley
Alabama Crimson Tide against the Auburn
Tigers I'm missing everything
I don't know what's going on in the
world I had a lot of people send me you
know tweets and texts and all that [ __ ]
unfortunately about the fatal crash so I
just clicked this [ __ ] thing off of
Roy Halladay and yeah that's [ __ ]
brutal that's brutal you see that guy in
Boston sports radio just [ __ ] went off
on him
you know it's hilarious about that whole
clip is he makes his point in the first
like eight seconds he says what he feels
about it and then continues to say it I
almost thought it was like on a loop he
just kept going oh look at me I got a
plan a I'm waving at the [ __ ] window
he said that like nine times I was kind
of done with the guy when he called
Halladay a jackwagon
who says that I understand you can't
curse on the radio I don't know but the
weird thing is that there's they're
blaming that they're starting to blame
the plane and I don't think that's right
I mean if it's pilot error at both times
I don't think that that you know what's
scary is the other one right I never
even thought about this the first time
that type of plane crashed
I guess the test pilot he went flying
into this Canyon flying low
and he they're guessing that he thought
he was in this different part of the
canyon that was gonna it opened up to a
lake but this one didn't like it started
to get narrow and then he went into
basically a mountain cul-de-sac and he
and basically the angle that he would
have had to fly out if he pulled back on
the stick he was gonna [ __ ] stall so
he had to try to do bang aue
basically I would think yeah that's why
I like a helicopter cuz you just go just
stop those [ __ ] things you have to
keep there like a shark they got to keep
moving forward other that's [ __ ] it
but I got to tell you man that plane
looks cool as hell it really does it
really looks cool and I don't know but
all of this [ __ ] where people speculate
and all that just shut the [ __ ] up
alright the FAA will investigate in like
whatever and in a certain amount of time
six months a year whatever they'll come
out with their official report all these
[ __ ] people who don't fly listen to
them talk about it was kind of I don't
know it's kind of funny like they said
no this is the third time you know
there's a lot of times if something's
easy people will do dumb [ __ ] with it
like the helicopter that I want to buy
you know it's it's basically like the
Robinson but they corrected all the
safety issues on it first of all having
a fully articulated main rotor system
well you could actually push the stick
forward and not enter into some sort of
low G or mass bumping situation so there
was a guy that got it and he was trying
to demonstrate how you could fly like an
[ __ ] which is what you should never
do and he slammed the stick forward and
he went into a nose down attitude but it
was it's a carbureted engine and the way
the fuel is fed in when he tipped it
forward he basically starved the
carburetor of fuel and he stalled it
demonstrating that he wouldn't get into
one situation he created another
situation and then he
crashed it so you know people always you
know the very little that I know about
aviation whenever a new design comes out
you know people are always like well
let's see let's let people fly in it and
let them die and then they can fix it
and let you warn you about all of this
stuff but a lot of times it's just
people it's this weird thing where they
make it safer and make it easier and
then someone will then do something I
don't know I'll do something like that
just slam a stick forward or something
so I have no idea what that guy was
doing but it's brutal that's obviously
condolences out to him and his wife and
kids man it's [ __ ] brutal alright
when with that sad frigging story that
guy in Boston radio though is also like
I feel like as much as he felt what he
was saying he was also trying to be edgy
you know and it's one of these things if
anything that he was saying was actually
true it's like dude you don't need to
say that why are you adding to the pain
of his family if you really give a [ __ ]
about his wife and kids all right if
somebody did something dumb everybody
knows that they did something dumb and
and then they died then shouldn't you
shut up about it it upsets you upset you
don't even know the [ __ ] guy it was
such a good Kardashian today I just felt
like for me that was really upsetting
anyways me undies everybody me on DS me
on DS don't slam the [ __ ] stick
forward to do it do it do it me on DS be
on DS if you're in a Capri [ __ ]
whatever I want to buy why would I go
into that why why the [ __ ] would I die
what can I say on DS me undies swing the
club nice the single Golf Club relaxed
doo doo doo doo bi Dee's me on Dee
yeah I got nothing that runs through the
legs cause I'm thinking that [ __ ] I'm
sorry you know what I feel like Casey
Kasem I just went from a tragic tragic
[ __ ] story to singing about underwear
right now wow you can't make that
transition me undies everybody me undies
makes you but me and ease your butt will
be proud to wear and check this out I'm
not the only one who loves me undies
listen to what longtime listener and me
undies enthusiast George has to say a
note from George and a Bill burr
listener and me undies fan I decided to
try out my undies BC because I love bill
bar there I said it okay sad what you
want all right I did it I tried on there
soft melody on the way my dick liked it
okay I smile every time he sings the
song although it's so easy to skip the
ads in the podcast I always listen to
Bill Reid bah bah bah bah bah you guys
know this he loves these [ __ ] things
they're nice and comfortable and he
loves me and he's cradling the family
jewels to get 20% off the best and
softest underwear and socks you will
ever own free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed go to me
a nice calm slash bird that's me and
ease calm slash bird well that was too
short I should probably read what the
guy said all right
I always listen to bills read and I'm so
glad me unease has stuck with them it's
been probably two years since I bought
my first pair of me undies and now I
have a monthly subscription because they
are that comfortable before me undies I
used to buy the 3-pack of underwear
retail stores until I realized that I
wanted to treat my junk to something
more comfortable and that starts with a
great pair of me undies cradling with
the family jewels that is just so slick
the way that is read it reeks of a vent
that it was rewritten by the advertisers
I'm sure there's a George n out there
but I don't think he wrote it as
eloquently as that if he did go to
Madison Avenue kid you got a career you
got a future
alright LegalZoom everybody as a
business owner you know how important it
is to keep moving forward but a lot of
times things come up that take your time
and focus away from growing your
business so when it comes to reviewing
contracts registering for trademarks or
staying current on fees and permits
legalzoom.com can help simplify your
life and they help more than two million
business owners easily and affordably
navigate the legal system with
confidence the best part you never have
to worry about an attorneys billable
hours piling up because Legal Zoom is
not a law firm instead you get the
advice you need to answer your business
questions at fixed rates through legal
zooms nationwide network of independent
attorneys so take some pressure off
yourself go to legalzoom.com now to take
care of your business before the year
winds down and for special savings be
sure to enter code BIR in the referral
box at checkout that's burpee you are
our for special savings only at
legalzoom.com alright let's continue on
here I've been so frigging busy
travelling around doing shows and
finishing up this acting gig that I have
not watched one second of my beloved
Boston Bruins and Boston Celtics I
haven't watched anything and a friend of
mine on f is for family a Cleveland
Cavaliers fan was raving about how well
Kyrie Irving was doing with the Celtics
so I watched a little bit of highlights
last night of the Celtics defeating the
Lakers I saw that Lonzo ball is that his
name or is that his dad's name I saw
that he actually played well and
believed in not even as a Celtics fan
I'm happy for that dude because his
[ __ ] dad is like such a crazy person
that it makes people hate this kid the
kids never said [ __ ] you can't pick your
parents and that dude's dad did a lot of
good things to his playing in the NBA
but I don't know what he's doing he's
[ __ ] wrestling I don't know what he's
doing I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing but that's gonna be one of those
things at some point that kid is gonna
have to make a very uncomfortable break
with this overbearing father but anyways
the Celtics won and I'm watching the
highlights and I don't know anybody on
the team anymore
we still got Marcus smart it seems like
we got rid of everybody else Crowder a
Bradlee Isiah Thomas I knew they were
all gone but you know Kelly olynyk's
gone everybody's [ __ ] God this like
two people left from last year's team
that kid Green was looking great what a
hell did he go I was all I I missed all
of these [ __ ] trades so I don't know
I'm right back to only being able to
name a couple of Celtics so I'm excited
that uh this I'm gonna get back into
them I'm gonna get through my my little
New York run here thank you by the way
to everybody that's coming out to my
show Sunday night in in New York City
thank you for getting bit in the tickets
you're gonna watch me try out some
material [ __ ] around do some [ __ ] that
works and do some [ __ ] that doesn't
quite work and but when I come back when
I come back I am that's it I'm watching
the NBA and NHL package and I'm so
[ __ ] psyched I'm going out I'll buy
my nieces and nephews a bunch of gifts
I'm gonna come back east for Christmas
everybody in my family who hasn't met my
beautiful gorgeous lovely daughter my
wife sent me video yesterday of the
first time she was on a swing watch out
you know thank God for video I would
have missed it was just awesome she was
so happy and then the way she was
sitting there she had like an elbow like
she was hanging out the driver's side
window
she was so totally chill she has like a
like like a relaxed confidence about her
and she's a sweetheart you know so all I
gotta do is not be an angry maniac you
know who kidding who I'm gonna be an
angry maniac but I'm gonna be less of
one and when she calls me out on it when
she inevitably learns how to talk I'm
just gonna admit to it and be like you
know what you're right daddy needs to
work on that cuz I don't know I don't
want to ruin what she looks like she's
gonna be mad cuz she just kids gonna be
special you know like all dads I am a
little biased but I'm telling you
anyways which is another reason to not
be boozing around the friggin house
right I think that's what I'm gonna do I
think in in in
the next year I'll keep my drinking on
the road that's what I'll do I'll live
this double life stone sober at home
pushing her on a swing wearing sweaters
smiling and waving and then on the road
I'll just be in the gutter after my
shows that's too sad I would never do
that anyways and I heard that kid for
the Bruins that kid on bu who stepped up
last year was looking looking very
promising I heard he's playing really
well I heard the Bruins of fast I know
we don't have the greatest record at
this point but you know it's a long
season I cannot [ __ ] wait to get back
to my family and just you know I don't
know I'm not gonna do [ __ ] for like two
weeks right through Thanksgiving right
to the end of this month and then oh you
know whatever it'll start getting busy
again but who gives a [ __ ] I'm gonna
really gonna try to enjoy the holidays
this year I'm getting into it alright
I'm gonna buy a [ __ ] tree I'm gonna
do the whole thing although where I
usually buy my tree you know got all of
you think got all [ __ ] up down there
now so they put me they can't sell the
trees there who knows what they're
probably knocking down the building to
put up another building that's the big
move out here right build these uh I
don't know what you call them these
high-rises luxury rentals do yourself a
favor don't rent a luxury apartment when
you can just instead go out and buy a
starter house throw all that money down
the [ __ ] toilet okay please don't do
that unless you want if you want to do
it by all means go ahead and do it so I
was reading I always read drum magazine
I read Modern Drummer magazine and I saw
this whole article on these drummers
favorite like prog rock bands from the
70s and you know early Genesis you know
in Peter Gabriel's still in it and Phil
Collins was on drums King Crimson all of
these bands so I actually started
listening to King Crimson that band at
that album red
and it's pretty [ __ ] out there this
[ __ ] is pretty [ __ ] out there some of
it doesn't hold up some of it does but
when they get into the real trippy
keyboard [ __ ] using all the effects and
everything that definitely gets a little
bit nuts but uh I don't know I was
always curious of like Bill Bruford
strumming like he was always on you know
the cover of all I like those magazines
I know he played in yes and all that
sudden he's this amazing drummer so it's
kind of psyched to finally be able to
hear him play but uh I don't know I
think I'm gonna listen to some of that
[ __ ] if anybody has any good suggestions
I know I can't help but feel like it's
very hipster II a lot of that I don't
get it too progressive I don't mind
fusion fusion is cool but progressive
gets a little uh you know reminds me of
Kevin Murphy what's what Kevin Murphy
listens to one efforts for family so but
I'll just treat it as like research or
whatever alright I'm babbling here once
again thanks everyone come out to my
show Sunday night and thanks to
everybody on front runner they gave me a
part here in this movie I had such a
great time on this shoot
met a bunch of people just awesome
people and I'm really excited to get
back to my family and just enjoy the
holidays and everything this is a great
time a [ __ ] year you know it would
have been nice that I could have said
that without cursing but I'm not the
brightest guy alright go [ __ ] yourselves
go Celtics go Patriots go Bruins
I don't know if we have a soccer team I
don't know what it is but I'm just
that's it man I'm going home I'm putting
on my [ __ ] pajamas and I ain't doing
[ __ ] for the rest of the [ __ ] year
except Christmas shopping cooking
Thanksgiving dinner flying back east
meeting a bunch of relatives giving out
gifts to no [ __ ] crisis it's always
busy isn't it who gives a [ __ ] alright
go [ __ ] yourselves and have a great
weekend
enjoy the music here and also we got in
another thirty minutes if you knew my
podcast we always play like the greatest
hits from a Thursday afternoon podcast
you know from a few years ago maybe this
year I don't [ __ ] know alright see
[Music]
you can be the best
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on it is bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 9 2009 and yes I am a
little late with this one it is well
into Monday evening here in Los Angeles
and I had I just had a whirlwind of a
week I really did I really did it should
have been my basically my Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
my last whatever that is five days
should have been filmed okay with like
that MTV style where just as you start
to focus on what the images they [ __ ]
quickly cut to what you were just
looking at from the side in a black and
black and white you know you know your
brother used to film up Punk'd and
Ashton Kutcher would be standing there
like okay
check it out um [ __ ] zippy Seacrest is
going to get a glazed donut right and
then BAM and they go from the side and
he be [ __ ] sitting there with his hat
sideways remember that I had like a
[ __ ] I had I had an I had like a
totally TRL experience I had an
unbelievable [ __ ] week you know why do
I feel like what I actually feel guilty
about it like telling you guys I had an
unbelievable week like I have to [ __ ]
apologize to you guys during a free
podcast [ __ ] you you know I got to tone
it down what cuz your week sucked why
can't you be happy for me
why didn't I turn the [ __ ] fan on
it's goddamn hot as [ __ ] hell you
know what it is about my apartment
no bill what is it hang on come on turn
on the problem is is I live in a desert
and this time of year the Sun there's
like 3-4 hours where it just beats down
right on the corner of my apartment and
it's just sitting there naked
there's no avocado tree or whatever
cactus or any [ __ ] to block out the Sun
so it just heats up like an oven and
then I always try to close the windows
you know I've explained this before
because I say [ __ ] a lot in the podcast
and I want my neighbor's to think I'm a
swell guy
no I don't I don't give a [ __ ] what they
think I just don't you know somebody
steal something I don't want them to
think it was me that's basically it all
right so this was my week listen to this
all you [ __ ] in your cubicles is it
Tuesday morning
did you already throw your hands up and
give up on me like I wasn't gonna
[ __ ] do it this week or at least
today shame on you
you could have been listening to this
yesterday at the end of your job you
know when you're supposed to be getting
all your spreadsheets in order huh
right around the time that egg salad
sandwich is starting to bug you and
you're thinking can I can I shoot it
right into the [ __ ] Staples office
chair that I'm sitting on that sorta has
some sort of foam underneath it isn't
that the worst ha when you have a
sit-down job and you have a chair you
can't fart into that's really bad you
know you got any got--we like 2 pairs of
boxers every time you have Mexican right
Jesus bill [ __ ] chokes 3 minutes right
right into the podcast huh this is how
it's gonna be sorry I was just adjusting
myself here not that kind of way just
adjust and everything cuz it's a long
[ __ ] story what I have to go through
to turn the fan on and keep a podcast
going I have to stretch the technology
out all the why is all right this is my
week alright Wednesday Wednesday I fly
to JFK New York City and because I'm
getting ready for my big townhall show
my first theater gig in New York City
right so I'm on my way there and I land
right around 5:30 just in time for the
[ __ ] traffic and lo and behold the
Yankees are playing game 6 of the
[ __ ] World Series
all right and if they win that night
they're gonna wrap this [ __ ] up I'm
staying in a hotel in Times Square
I bring my girl along right it's a big
[ __ ] week for me
you know and I'm sitting there riding
and going please let the Phillies win
please let the [ __ ] Phillies win you
know and then win Game seven so I can
walk watch all those [ __ ] sad-sack
Yankee fans with those satin Yankee
jackets that they wear you know like
they're in some biker gang on [ __ ]
happy days I don't they're like one of
the only team
left it still has those satin [ __ ]
jackets anyways but it was not to be
right then I started to watch Game six
and Pedro's on the mound and he starts
off with like an 84 mile an hour
fastball and I just really had a bad
feeling that I was gonna watch the end
of his career that night and he was
gonna let up like 17 runs and I couldn't
watch it so I shut it off so I have to
do Opie and Anthony in the morning so I
take my vitamins I go to sleep or
whatever try not to get sick on the road
and right around right around right as
I'm starting to nod off I hear the first
screaming that I would hear for the next
three hours I just hear like way off you
know basically what I'm sitting Times
Square is about a half a block away so
all I hear right as I'm about ready to
nod off and get a nice eight hours sleep
right before I go to do the morning
radio all of a sudden I just hear like
right could really make it out wasn't
that clear and then I started here sorry
he's horns blowing and it was like the
whole [ __ ] stadium I guess they want
it I figured it out at that point that's
like the whole [ __ ] stadium decided
what do we do now let's go to Times
Square and keep Bill up for the next
[ __ ] three hours and that's what they
did and it was so loud it's so
ridiculous I was actually sitting there
with my head in between two pillows like
I was having a [ __ ] like like a head
sandwich right it was so [ __ ] loud
and so ridiculous I was actually laying
there laughing I mean what are the
[ __ ] odds right one of the corner
than one of the biggest Red Sox fans one
of the guys who hates the Yankees the
most okay I live 3,000 miles away what
are the [ __ ] odds this one random day
I'm gonna fly in and they're gonna win
the World Series and they're gonna
decide to celebrate half a [ __ ] block
away so that was my first night and the
next night I did a gig for actually I
didn't hike this gig because
trying to sell tickets for my townhall
gig and I actually on Thursday I opened
for this up-and-coming comedian then I'm
sure all you guys you're gonna know
about soon guy by the name of Dane Cook
I don't know if you've ever heard of him
just you know up-and-coming guy you know
just just trying to plug away I opened
up format on Madison Square Garden I did
ten minutes and it was wasn't like the
theater at Madison Square Garden it was
where the Knicks play and I'm trying to
think the last time I worked with him on
the road I think maybe we did a college
gig together about 15 years ago way back
when we were starting out in Boston so
it was I got to tell you that's it's
been a long time since I did a gig that
wasn't like if I do Letterman I get
butterflies but it's been a long time
since I've done a stand-up gig where I
got that wasn't gonna be on TV and I
actually got butterflies I I was
standing back there waiting to go on and
I was like legitimately not like nervous
to the point that there was gonna [ __ ]
with my set but I was like I don't know
what it was
I stumped because I can I cut if it's
right and fortunately I had the presence
of mind to be like you know what when
are you ever gonna get to do this again
bill I'm gonna go with never I'm gonna
bet I bet the longshot on this one and
guess that you're never gonna get to do
this again so or most likely you know
Never Say Never
so why don't you go up there and [ __ ]
enjoy it and right before Dane does his
shows in the round so it's like 20,000
[ __ ] people and I'm sitting there
looking at the stage and I'm trying to
figure out Who am I gonna look at so
fortunately before I went out there I go
Dane exactly how does this
theater-in-the-round work it he goes
it's no big deal he goes it's just like
it's like for theatres there's one in
front of you one to the right one to the
left and one behind you just break it up
like that then all of a sudden it didn't
it it just made sense and I went out
there he actually had a great I mean I
was freaking out I knew I was gonna be
doing the gig for about six days and I
was just going oh my god
is this gonna be a bunch of Facebook
hotties and I'm gonna go up there saying
[ __ ] every other word and they're just
gonna be looking at me like Wednesday
and coming on this guy is angry but they
weren't they were [ __ ] awesome and
they totally listened and I was probably
uh one of the best ten minutes sets I
think I've ever had as far as uh how
many times you get to do a ten minute
set and you get to look up at a Stanley
Cup champion banner you know by the way
why is Madison Square Garden I'm not
trying to be a dick here why is it
considered a basketball mecca they
always say that like a Michael Jordan
would go that's you know it's a
basketball Mecca LeBron James it's a
basketball there we say that it's a
basketball Mecca all right now
fans of the New York Knicks all right
and you're a true fan right now if
you're still watching those bumps okay
you're going through a real rough patch
I wanna I want you to justify send me an
email and tell me explain to me how
Madison Square Garden is considered a
basketball Mecca how okay the Knicks
haven't won a championship since 1972 I
think they won their other one in like
69 or 70 they've won two championships
the [ __ ] Spurs have won like what
four five how is Madison Square Garden a
basketball Mecca if that's a mecca what
was the old Boston Garden we won 16
there I'll say like the LA forum the LA
forum they won five six seven I don't
know what they won there they want a
good they want like nine I think they
won nine out there okay if if Madison
Square gonna find out being a dick here
New York City is a basketball Mecca that
rutger park or whatever the [ __ ] it is
with a goat
right he used to [ __ ] lift up a
refrigerator and put it on top of the
backboard he's not Holly the urban myth
goes or whatever the [ __ ] it was Lew
Alcindor right all those guys came from
there I understand that I understand all
those players but
there's only been [ __ ] there's two
championship banners hanging in Madison
Square Garden okay so I'm gonna kind of
be a jerk here and say that it's not a
basketball Mecca I don't think you've
earned the right but college basketball
maybe you know I don't know I think yeah
I think you guys really need to win a
lot more the [ __ ] Chicago Bulls went
six in the 90s well it's the first three
at Old Chicago Stadium and then the
other three what if the United Center is
that I win I don't I don't [ __ ] know
all I'm saying is you guys need to bring
that down a little bit you know that's
like you ever see like when you see a
restaurant they they'll say welcome to
two world famous blah blah blahs and
you're sitting there really really they
they know about this in Portugal they
don't you just saying that and I think
that [ __ ] you know what Madison Square
Garden is just like Ray's famous pizza
in New York City every [ __ ] one
claims to be there's a couple of cut
there's a couple of comedy clubs the
what the world-famous [ __ ] yuck yep
slapping E whatever the [ __ ] they call
him it's like it's not world-famous it's
not alright
it isn't okay that I did I beat that to
death I really got off the rails here
let me get back to my [ __ ] story here
alright so the first night I go Yankees
win the World Series and their fans keep
me up for like three hours
alright and oh I actually congratulated
the Yankees on on the radio the next day
which is probably very surprising to a
lot of people if you'd like to hear it
go to uh just Google Bilborough
Opie and Anthony show Yankee rant for
some reason they called it a rant but I
was actually congratulating them and I
meant everything that I said and it
might have sounded like I was being a
little sarcastic but I wasn't anyways
let me plow ahead so the next night I
opened for Dane at Madison Square Garden
right I'm [ __ ] his pictures like
Frank Sinatra and in Elvis I'm talking
to the security guard who's been there
for 40 years he's pointing out where
Mike Milbury went into the stands and
beat that guy with his own [ __ ] shoe
right you guys ever seen that and of
course not you're not hockey fans
actually
look look up Boston Bruins fight fans
just look that up is a Bruins Rangers
game and I think it was Terry O'Reilly
somebody grabbed his stick and they hit
him with it thinking you know typical
fan like that like that's not a real guy
he's on skates I have [ __ ] Chuck
Taylors on he can't catch me I don't
know how he did it but Terry O'Reilly
climbed up the [ __ ] glass and grabbed
this guy and then the rest of the Bruins
followed him in the stands and this is
how far we've come as a society back
then that was probably a story for about
five days there were lawsuits or
whatever but you never heard about there
was no [ __ ] ESPN it was it came and
it went there wasn't suspended for life
you know no Latrell Sprewell kind of
[ __ ] nothing they went up there they
beat fans with their own clothing and
then they went back on the ice and they
finished the [ __ ] game as far as I
know anyway so then Friday night I I did
my first theater gig and I want to thank
everybody who came out there was a huge
milestone in my career to be able to
perform at a theater in New York City
and sell the thing out everything went
awesome I got a standing ovation and had
three killer comics on in front of me
Joe DeRosa Paul virzi and then there was
this girl of this contest winner and of
course her name escapes me at this point
because I talk on my cell phone too much
and I can't remember any [ __ ] thing
anymore
oh and speaking of that [ __ ] no no stay
on track though stay on track because I
was making a couple of Corrections from
last week but uh so Saturday night comes
Saturday night I was up in Boston I did
the comics come home with Cam Neely and
Denis Leary and all that type of [ __ ]
and that was in front of 6,000 people so
basically over three days I went on in
front of almost 25,000 people and now
I'm sitting in my bedroom talking to
myself into an orange [ __ ] microphone
so you know I'm coming down a little bit
getting back to reality you know how's
that for a [ __ ] weekend I can't
believe it
unbelievable
I can't believe it and then he says
unbelievable just in case you didn't
realize that it was unbelievable right
now you know what's funny about me I'm
actually self-conscious right now that I
talked about so much good [ __ ] that
happened to me that's that's what it's
like to be [ __ ] German Irish Catholic
from Boston that's what it is oh my god
a bunch of good stuff happened I should
feel guilty you know and I almost said
[ __ ] you to you guys like you're
actually you give a [ __ ] either way I
really got issues all right let's uh
let's make a couple of Corrections all
right last week that racist movie I was
trying to remember the name of its Birth
of a Nation and I want to thank the 87
people who brought that to my attention
and I also mentioned I was going to read
a book about how to speak better on
stage use using my voice correctly and
people wanted to know the name of the
book that I was reading actually lied to
you I'm not reading it I keep starting
the book but it's really involved it's
just like your diaphragm there's
emotional room your door a border you
know I'm just like oh my god I hate
school and I close it and then I'll read
like Slash's autobiography or like
what's the guy from the Red Hot Chili
Peppers Anthony Kiedis I'm sort of
skipping around his biography but the
name of the book is called freeing the
natural voice by Kristen Linklater all
right Li NK
and I have a tendency yell from my
throat rather than down here by the
[ __ ] diaphragm you like that hear
that that's [ __ ] Ray's famous pizza
that's an awful burger from a diner and
that's some bar pizza that I got up in
Boston trying so hard to get in shape I
just don't think it's gonna happen
[ __ ] that Pat the whole [ __ ] goddamn
summer to get in shape and I didn't do
it I've been a [ __ ] idiot like usual
I'm waiting to the last week like one of
these chicks on the shows right now I
just don't eat then I show up in a
strapless dress with my [ __ ] my
[ __ ] I was it's a clavicle showing is
that said there was that a word
collarbone there you go what is it
clavicle is that that thing on your back
that looks like a sail what is that your
shoulder blade is that called a claw
I don't [ __ ] remember radius on the
tarsals metatarsals phalanges
anyways let's uh let's plow ahead here
with the podcast so I'm actually now I'm
like hardcore there's no turning back I
have to drop like ten pounds before my
special or my big [ __ ] TV kitchen
kitchen TV sized head is gonna look
[ __ ] ridiculous on TV so I really got
it I gotta get the booze weight off and
I'm actually just went for a bike ride I
was hiking up one of these parks out
here out here Griffith Park
you know the observatory you guys ever
see that James Dean movie then he filmed
something up there or Charlie's Angels
and when those for skinny [ __ ] are up
there with their Botox and their [ __ ]
[ __ ] hanging out remember that last
scene yeah that that's the observatory
so the other day I was hiking up to it
on foot and I see this [ __ ] it's like
55 year old guy white hair pedaling up
the hill like he's in a [ __ ] viagra
commercial and I'm going look at that
son of a [ __ ] you know when he had all
that he had always had the whole getup
on you know the whole Lance Armstrong
outfit like he's gonna you know ride
through Paris and throw his hands up
right under the octa triumph right
rather than he's just riding up a hill
in the middle of a desert sucking in bus
[ __ ] fumes but I was impressed I was
like you know what if that old bastard
can do it you know and I got to admit
55 in LA is like 32 the way these people
workout out here all right and I'm sorry
to the people in the middle in the
middle of this country and down south
all right I love it people do that when
they have one they insult you and then
they say they're sorry but you know
they're not you know I get that a lot at
the end of my shows III didn't think you
were funny you know I mean I'm sorry I
didn't and I'm always like okay yeah
yeah cuz you know it's like I know other
people did but you know it's like you
know I'm sorry I just I just didn't why
do you keep a Paul you're not sorry
you're not sorry okay I got it you don't
like me and I don't give a [ __ ] because
you already paid for a ticket you paid
to watch me annoy you and I find that
I find that humorous um anyways let's
plow ahead so I figured I gave myself
ten days to be able to [ __ ] make it
all the way up to this goddamn hill and
I just did it today and I made it all
the way up to the top
Michael idea I feel like I'm gonna
[ __ ] die but I actually made it up
there so now I don't know what to do
I thought that that was gonna be my
project I would just do that every day
and every day I get a little bit farther
and while I would focus on the carrot in
front of me I would just drop this booze
wait right but what happens the first
[ __ ] day I go all the way up the
goddamn thing so now what do I do you
know what I got to do I got to join a
gym and I got at Row two weights around
that's what I got to do you know in the
mail today I got a free 30 days at
Gold's Gym anybody work at a gym how is
this free 30 days gonna work out for me
sign up for 3:30 for free 30 I can't
even [ __ ] talk the hell's wrong with
me I know what's wrong with me I [ __ ]
flown like 200 hours on a plane the last
goddamn two months you should have seen
this [ __ ] douchebag putting his coat
in the overhead compartment on my flight
out here I couldn't tell if this guy had
the biggest yarmulke on I had ever seen
in my life or he had just shrunk his
jazz hat you know you know those little
jazz hats that those black guys wear and
then that white guys wear when when they
get into jazz to try to act like they
get it too you know those ones though
the African colors you know and you just
sit there talking about Charlie Parker
you know and your version of salt
peanuts or whatever the [ __ ] it is and I
don't know what it was any Jewish people
listen to this [ __ ] huh let me ask you a
question is it technically still a
yarmulke when it almost goes to the
front of the guys hairline and all the
way to it I mean this thing it looked
like a [ __ ] of what is that thing the
Mexicans dude they use the the tortilla
right Oh
like an ignorant mi of every goddamn
culture out there I thought a yarmulke
was it was a beanie is that incorrect
I call him a beanie for a long time and
I always used to get looks I was like
yeah the guy had the [ __ ] and I had the
[ __ ] beanie thing the and then I get
looks and it's like all's cuz I cursed
I say [ __ ] when I'm trying to gather my
thoughts sometimes the [ __ ] beanie
rather than saying the og what is that
thing called the beanie I put the
[ __ ] in front of it and then it adds
an extra edge to it inadvertently then
people like oh my god he doesn't like
Jewish people with hats
is it a beanie or is a beanie that thing
with the little propeller on top of it
and another question did anybody ever
have those does anybody old enough to
actually answer that [ __ ] question is
that one of those Hollywood things
cartoon things that they just acted like
people used to have those back in the
day I know kids used to wear those
little raccoon hats you know back when
there was game all over the place you
know mothers made pies and stuck them on
window sills Stanley if you're gonna
shoot it you better cook it we're gonna
have to eat it right did white people
ever say that or do we just waste have
we always just wasted [ __ ] we've always
had the MTV Cribs approach to [ __ ]
nature haven't we white people didn't
Buffalo Bill used to just ride around
shooting Buffalo in the head laughing
his ass off through that fu-manchu's
that connected to his sideburns you know
what how much more did you increase your
odds of having your legs soda off like
so Duff sawed off while you drank brandy
if you had that little [ __ ] that foo
Manchu what does that one called
as far as the facial hair I'm asking a
lot of questions maybe I should have
done some research the only person I've
seen with that is that guy Lemmy from
Motorhead and then afterwards the dude
from Metallica had it he had it for a
minute there James Hetfield why don't we
get to the questions here I seem to be
asking a lot of questions here why don't
I get to some of your questions and I'll
try to answer them question Billy I have
two questions I can't help but notice
these [ __ ] annoying commercials and
ads about selling your gold
I wondered whether or not you thought
this was a conspiracy to round up all
the gold still owned by individuals so
that when the dollar completely tanks
the people won't have anything of worth
for themselves no I don't think it's a
conspiracy I just think that those guys
late night are doing a much smaller
version of the scam that bankers did
originally is what they're doing is
they're taking gold and they're just
giving people a piece of paper for it
but it's not as bad as when the banks
did it the banks did it they said give
us your gold and we'll give you these
little pieces of paper that are
redeemable anytime you want you can come
back and get your gold and needless to
say eventually you couldn't claim your
gold anymore
and they just sort of kept it no one
knows where it is because you can't
audit them so yeah that's what those
guys are doing they're anticipating I
probably the tanking of the dollar they
get me I don't know if you guys have you
seen those commercials with it just like
I just do a bit about it you know if you
got an old class ring if you got a
broken bracelet if you got some busted
jewelry sand in your gold and we will
give you cash for it that's what they're
doing and for those of you who think I'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you had a sandwich
shop and somebody walked in and tried to
buy a sand sandwich with some rubles you
tell them to go [ __ ] themselves but if
somebody who came from a country that
used to use rubles but add a handful of
gold you know you still would be like
dude what the [ __ ] I don't know what
gold is trading at but you'd know that
the gold had value okay that's the great
thing about gold all around the [ __ ]
world you can get yourself a goddamn
sandwich with a piece of gold I
challenge you to buy anything with the
[ __ ] ruble go ahead and do it or some
defunct the yen do they have that
anymore in Japan have bill you're
getting in over your head shut the [ __ ]
up just keep moving so no I don't think
that that's a conspiracy I just think
that that's one of the oldest scams in
the book and JP Morgan and the guys it
was a Jekyll's island or whatever
Federal Reserve those guys perfected it
god bless him
shame on us fool me once shame on you
fool us for a [ __ ] hundred years and
yeah we're [ __ ] morons okay next one
also I'll be coming in Cleveland to see
you and wondered if the same guy that
opened for you in Pittsburgh will be
opening for you in Cleveland as well oh
that was Doug soon yay Doug same yay
getting some props ducks and a hilarious
I kind of rotate my openers when I go to
Cleveland who's it gonna be Ryan Dalton
and Jason lawhead actually two guys that
I've known for about five years right
now they're based out of Cleveland
travel all around absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious and I lose half my liver every
time I go out there and work with them
so I love those guys and they're gonna
be opening they're [ __ ] hilarious so
if you're wondering if I'm gonna have a
funny opener yes I am
next question bill as a say of bills and
a Sabres fan I think I have it the worse
with to loss Stanley Cups and for lost
Super Bowls and eleven years of eleven
years without a playoff appearance do
you think I'm right
no I don't I do not I think you
definitely have it bad but for the
longest time everybody talked about
Boston and then we want a bunch of [ __ ]
so that was over and they have been
talking about the Cubs blah blah blah
blah blah but I think the worst city to
be a fan in right now is Cleveland very
quietly those guys have gone my entire
life and nobody has won anything the
Cleveland Browns have never won a
Superbowl the Cleveland Cavaliers have
never won an NBA championship and the
Cleveland Indians haven't won a World
Series since 1948 so unless you're in
your 70s for all extensive purposes the
Indians have never won a World Series do
you understand that because you got to
be like at least like eight years old
nine years old to remember a [ __ ]
World Series now some douchebags gonna
email me actually always Shakespeare Joe
when the Tigers won 1868 who gives a
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying don't be a
[ __ ] alright so I would say that they
have it worse
but yeah you guys are you know you're
right there you're right there with them
that's one of those things it's like do
you really want to win that argument
remember a long time ESPN a long time
ago ESPN did who has the who had the
worst curse the Boston Red Sox or the
Chicago Cubs and they did this stupid
trial and they had like George went from
cheers who's a Chicago guy he's arguing
to be like no we're more miserable and
it's just like all right you want to win
that contest that's all you who the [ __ ]
would want to win the misery contest
that's really beyond me so
congratulations you didn't win it I
think people in Cleveland are what I
think how do you think those guys feel
have two [ __ ] guys with World Series
rings this year used to be used to be on
the [ __ ] Indians we're half the guys
in the World Series right CC Sabathia
nah [ __ ] who was the other guy god
dammit I had him right at the tip I got
a stop talking on my cell phone
Manny Ramirez okay we'll see how the
last couple years Manny Ramirez a Red
Sox bought him right CC Sabathia the
[ __ ] Yankees bought that dude via the
Brewers who else did Jim Thome play on
the Phillies last year I mean the
Indians should have want it they should
have won it but the way baseball is is
you know it's not competitive anymore
that's why I'm kind of I think I'm
tapping out on baseball I don't give a
[ __ ] anymore
I don't know in my world competition I
was right actually wrote an email to a
guy about this I my world competition is
our best guys first your best guy's best
team wins that's to me is competition
I don't think competition is our best
guys plus your best guys verse whatever
the [ __ ] you have left stupid you know
she's been when you were kids and you'll
be choosing up sides you know and right
off the bat if two of the best guys were
on the same side or in the end it seemed
uneven pwill and what I was from and
that was called schmuck teams SMU CK
I've never heard that anywhere else I
was like sucked with an eminent schmuck
people ignore small teams he teams a
schmuck I know what the [ __ ] that's
that should have been said like during
the Little Rascals era but some reason
it was said during my childhood these
are schmuck teams so then he had to
break him up you had to break up the
evil empire the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
Yankees or the Red Sox Dodgers or
whatever any one of these teams I mean
the Yankees are in a league of their own
but you know I'm saying
Red Sox and all them are just as much
part of the [ __ ] problem they would
break up any of those kids know enough
to break up those [ __ ] teams alright
anyways plowing ahead let's read what
the [ __ ] was I gonna read here questions
I already did that this is called broads
over there broads over there I don't
know what the hell it says let's read
this one bill I have been a fan of yours
some time just want to tell you that I
think you're great thank you why don't I
[ __ ] delete those I think your comedy
but but the but there Thanks all right
anyways the reason I am writing you is
to tell you a funny story my girl dating
five plus years now and I live in Tucson
Arizona and she is always bitching at me
saying we never do anything anymore well
my job is very consuming of my time and
I realized that she was correct so what
do I do
so what I do is I try to come up with
something we could do together that
would be entertaining and unique
something different that is not an
average night out in Tucson see the guys
used in his brain trying to surprise her
anyways I've been telling her about your
comedy and showing her clips of you that
I found on your MySpace page for the
past few months she really seemed to
enjoyed it and laughed hysterically so I
planned this great evening for the 20th
Nova of November which goes something
like this head up to temp Eve have a
nice dinner and head over to the improv
and watch your show your eight o'clock
show well I bought the tickets and
thought I would surprise her with the
whole thing she loved the idea and she
was very excited and I was supposed to
pleased to see her excited about the
event well we were telling our friends
about it and she sort of says this well
it's his evening and I'm just thought of
tagging along I got to admit that I was
a little upset at this point because I
intended this whole thing to be a gift
from me to her which is funny because
this is very similar to the story that
you told
on October 19 on the October 19th
podcast when you took your girl in the
Corvette up the PCH she just soda shut
she just showed it sort of shut me down
so my question to you is why is it never
enough what a great question do you
realize you just asked the question of
probably every guy on this [ __ ]
podcast how long I'm just gonna pause
here while the women roll their eyes oh
my god that's [ __ ] that's not true
it's just you know you gotta use your
imagination women like surprises they
just [ __ ] shut up just shut up
would you you just shut up and take off
all those [ __ ] layers it's not the
1800s you know with your panties and
your pantyhose and your slip and your
[ __ ] skirt all right what am I
talking about I don't know um anyways
wait I lost nice place so my question to
you is why is it never enough I can do
everything she wants but she would still
find a way to make me look like an
[ __ ] making me uh making it seem like
I'm dragging her around and making her
do all that stuff that I want to do I
guess that is why I relate to your
comedy because it seems that she is only
happy when we do all the things that she
wants to do you know what I'm talking
you know want to talk about with brunch
street fairs in the candle store
nevertheless we are going and really
looking forward to seeing you in person
hope to see you have to show selling
some CDs and DVDs alright um why is it
never enough I don't know I don't know
why I don't know if it's an insecurity
that they are they're always questioning
whether you truly love them or not I
have no idea I don't know why I mean I
would think that all right look at me
okay I wouldn't I rented a Corvette for
the day Corvette Convertible and I drove
my girl all around LA we went up the
[ __ ] Pacific Coast Highway looked at
the ocean we had lunch I took her out to
this beautiful bar late at night I drove
it through the Hollywood
with the top down looking at the stars
looking at the lights out over the city
I thought it was a very romantic thing
and then I got on the podcast and she
was just like yeah that was really just
that was really your thing I just did
that for you you know I just sort of sat
there in a $70,000 automobile
you know seeing views that people fly
six hours to see and just you know just
got a free lunch out of it and free
[ __ ] drinks and ever watch The Price
is Right
there you spit on my own microphone I
never the price is right you have watch
The Price is Right sure we all have okay
getting a Corvette I mean like and then
going to that restaurant and driving up
to PCH and looking at the lights and
going out to the [ __ ] bar in the
hotel with John Belushi od'd isn't that
that sounds like one of the one of those
showcases that did you bid on
are you gonna bid are you gonna pass you
know oh dude you know what speaking of
that I was watching I was watching The
Price is Right the other day and I had
like a white guilt moment okay
this this black dude goes up to go spin
the big [ __ ] wheel alright and you
know you know the deal for those of you
who don't live in this country you
basically you spin the wheel whoever
comes close to a dump
closest to a dollar without going over
gets to then go on and bid on the big
surprises all right that's for people in
England and Australia and all that [ __ ]
email me if you don't know the show so
basically they have every denomination
from 5 cents 10 cents 15 30 40 45 50 55
60 all the way up to one dollar so this
like 55 year old black dude spins the
wheel and it stops on 30 cents okay now
you can decide to stay or spin again now
I'm not a [ __ ] math petition but I
think you want to hit on 30 cents right
you want he's looking out at the crowd
I'm like is this guy [ __ ] kidding me
and I'm kind of laughing going alright
he's a little bit old he's a little bit
older right his family's gonna
straighten it out for him and he looks
out in the crowd
I don't know if they told him I don't
know what the [ __ ] they told him but he
goes I'm gonna stay he stayed on thirty
cents and I'm looking at Drew Carey
going like alright I know what Bob
Barker would do Bob Barker would be like
okay wait a minute
you sure you want to stay on this thirty
cents is really low he would have helped
him through it but Drew Carey just went
like he's gonna stay on 30 cents alright
let's bring up the next person so the
dude is standing there with the 30 cents
up above him and I wanted to laugh my
ass off and be like what a stupid [ __ ]
but then I felt guilty because it was a
black dude and I'd be white laughing at
this black guy like he's a [ __ ] and
that's one of the that's the worst thing
about racists is they ruined your
ability to be able to laugh at a [ __ ]
because he's another color then all
because all of a sudden it becomes this
ugly thing you know I'll go [ __ ] what
color you are if you're playing a game
we're trying to come close to $1 and you
stop at 30 cent you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
I should be able to laugh and I was
laughing and then I felt bad and then I
actually thought oh [ __ ] someone's gonna
take that clip and they're gonna put it
up on YouTube and then someone's gonna
write a bunch of racist [ __ ] underneath
it rather than sticking with the subject
that this individual who happens to be a
black dude is a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
or at the very least didn't understand
how the game worked look at that I think
it still had to give him the benefit of
the doubt a [ __ ] game show that's
been on 40 [ __ ] years Jesus Christ
how did I get on that subject alright
let's get back here so my question is
why is it never enough you know what my
girls got the flu right now how funny
would it be if I actually called her in
here right now with the flu to ask her
this question I'm really jeopardizing my
relationship should I do it everybody I
think I'm gonna do it hang on one second
let me see if I can get her in here hold
on
all right she's coming and don't say
anything right
watch me to finance my way through this
all right
making her way in ladies and gentlemen
making her triumphant return to the
podcast look at you yeah officially sick
officially sick pajamas socks is that
orange juice or you got any booze in
there okay yes it is everything don't
worry Cleo we'll get it um all right
here's a question for you here's a
question one of my listeners had all
right I'm not trying to be hostile here
this is a female question I know we had
a big battle about that dude who punched
that chick in the face right Rihanna and
Chris Brown we had a big argument on the
plane about that it's really bad
[Music]
all right should we talk about that
argument Oh should we get into this and
then we'll do the argument then we'll
wrap it up then we'll segue there you go
all right
I'll read this to you and then you have
to get have to come closer to the mic
here um don't look over my shoulder she
reads way faster than me it makes me
self-conscious all right basically
there's this guy he's got a girl I want
to paraphrase my listeners don't have
listen to this [ __ ] again they've been
dating for five years she always
complains that they never do anything
because the job is very time-consuming
he admits this his job is very
time-consuming okay all right
we're on the same page we're ready to go
okay listen she starts coughing I've
been doing this to her every day all day
long I make a laugh so she starts
coughing she's like listen to you Sully
you selling you worked in a mine
that's horrible God how did I ever find
you attractive I'm joking
you know I'm joking I told you you're
adorable all right so anyway easy easy
she says oh my god this is horrible you
sound horrible
all right stop doing that be a performer
here okay
all right Jerry Lewis would it just yeah
anyways lady see what a great sets a
humor she's got even with 105 degrees so
no it's not that he doesn't take her she
just said he doesn't take her anyway
do you understand that yes okay she's
claiming that they don't go anyway and
he admits that he works a lot and he
might not have enough time there okay
just don't side with the broad cuz she
has a [ __ ] here all right yeah I know I
had to go there makes the guys laugh
alright so anyways so then he just so he
decides he's gonna take her somewhere so
he sees that I'm gonna be coming in town
right he starts showing clips of me on
MySpace page of course she starts
laughing cuz I'm [ __ ] hilarious right
we know this thank you alright so he
goes all right this is perfect so he
gets tickets to my 8 o'clock show he's
gonna take her out to dinner he's gonna
take her out to the comedy show she says
that's not a good idea he says yeah so
he psyched he feels like he's fixed the
problem so the next night they're
talking about it to their friends and he
says where he's gonna go and what
they're gonna do what should we have
done what should we do remember that no
Reservoir Dogs so you like telling jokes
huh giggling like a bunch of girls in a
schoolyard sorry I know I do bad
impressions terrible I know so anyway so
then he finally ends up saying it too he
brings it up she brings out in front of
her friends and she said well it's his
evening and I'm just sort of tagging
along
alright and he goes I got omit that I
was a little upset
at the point because I intended this
whole evening thing to be a gift from me
to her so he goes it reminded me of when
you took your girl out in the Corvette
and you said the same thing right so he
says my question to you is why is it
never enough I love it you're
tongue-tied look at see what you're
doing right now no say what you're
exactly say exactly what you're thinking
don't do this if you try to figure a way
to spin this [ __ ] don't spin it because
it's not like it's not enough but I
think where she's coming from it's not
like the whole he it's done it's over
it's like I said it comes from this
point of insecurity that you guys never
feel loved enough it's hard but yeah
okay he is a fan of yours first she she
became a fan of yours but he is like a
longtime fan so even though she would
enjoy seeing your show of course it's he
has more of a connection to you and your
your comedy than she does he has more
invested because he's he likes you and
she had just heard of you I guess when
he introduced her to your clips on
YouTube and stuff so in a way it's like
oh well I like it and I'll show it to
her and oh she thinks it's funny so
we'll make a night out of it but it's
not as if I don't know what else she
likes I mean I'm sure she likes going
shopping and so basically the fact that
he didn't say hey you know what I have
the afternoon free you want to like go
to the farmers market or go like window
shopping or whatever that would have
been an evening or an afternoon all
about her that's like the difference and
so can I interrupt right now it's a
relationship there's two people it's not
her birthday I understand if it's her
birthday it's all about her she go she
never take me anywhere so basically the
problem here is the place that he's
taking her to he can actually have a
good time at he should actually take her
to something that he doesn't want to do
no I think the issue is that she would
have maybe preferred it
was a hundred percent all about her so
you guys are selfish specifically that
she wanted to do I don't know if she saw
for sure night well it sounds like she's
a little she's being a little bratty
about it now though I'll take that that
was very high you know what I appreciate
that they know what the fact that you've
actually admitted at least to that now I
can listen to your opinion
a lot more open mind and Lee okay
especially to her friends but what do
you think I would do what do you what do
you think I would do if you did that if
you made that comment front of your
friends okay and then I've already I but
I've already stopped talking to us we're
coming home all we hear is this silent
were of our Prius see that starts off
you know I understand it out what it was
was I love the Corvette long before I
loved you so it really was something
more about me then I smiling too much
that day is that what bugged you [ __ ]
amazing it was not one of the things
when you mention it I was like no wait a
minute
as far as your days that you've had out
here in LA where does that one rank see
a random day in October that was a
[ __ ] big time scorer and you still had
to be like wow that was really kind of
your thing why would you do that no no
no wait wait wait wait I have memory
problems wait when did I say what I
wasn't me I saying you weren't being
bratty with what you just said that's
not what I meant
look me I can't remember anything for I
don't have any short-term memory anymore
so I don't know who that guy
I don't know if I was agreeing with you
I'm never taking this stand if I ever
kill anybody because I'm not going to be
able to test you guys have to hang on a
second why I kiss my sick girlfriend
there you go
see that see that guys I didn't have to
slap her around I didn't have to call
any of them names over there like Chris
Brown let me ask you this now would most
women just automatically see that with
the idea so then would she get
self-conscious and feel like she had to
call call it out before they set it
would she maybe say that because she's
kind of embarrassed that that that
didn't like yeah like she cuz if he said
it you know you know what are you doing
oh he's taking me see this guy bilberry
says [ __ ] every other word that's what
he's doing on this romantic night god
damn it I think she might be right
[Music]
okay last question tell me you didn't
feel like you were dating Paul Newman
when we were driving up the [ __ ] PCH
with the top down you didn't feel like
Nia Woodward you did exactly the [ __ ]
great idea oh and put it in a special
spot Pat back then underneath that that
overhang so the shade would be would be
all nice and cool you know they don't do
that when you pull up in the Prius do
they let's stick that [ __ ] right out in
the Sun all right so let's let's get
let's get on to let's get on to our
argument so where we're flying back from
New York City how amazing was I a Town
Hall
amazing standing ovations that's right
you [ __ ] right am how insecure am i
that I had to make you say that for the
sixth time
exactly all right so let's plow ahead
here so we're flying back from where we
were Boston at that point and I don't
know if we had already watched the
YouTube clip or whatever Rihanna had
gone on TV talking to Diane Sawyer
breaking it down talking about you know
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of her by
that dude with the beaver teeth right he
does he has no business being a pop star
he bit her too right why wouldn't you
you got to utilize your weapons so we're
sitting there and it's just real it's
just really sad interview and she's just
like I just felt silly and stupid for
being so this is what I did so it
started off as a joke and I said all
right this is my impression all right
well this is the deal I was talking
about how they she was just saying that
you know I found an inappropriate text
message and then things escalated and
then next thing you know he caved in my
cheek and started biting me and blah
blah blah blah blah and I was just like
you know what she left out a lot of the
details and because what I've learned
with arguing with women is when women
argue when you they're not winning or
they're not getting you to admit that
you're wrong
at some point they make this switch in
there whether they're just like I'm just
gonna make this person as mad as I
possibly can by using every ounce of
information that I know about them so
truth yeah you know what that's as good
as a yes anyway so this is one of those
in the moment jokes I can't even what
they said I said this is my impression
of the conversation before I can't
remember what how I did it though I was
like wish you see from Barbados but for
some reason I started doing this really
bad Jamaican accent
and I got llaman young man who be
sending you the text man yo [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I ain't gonna say nothing
yo man who gave you the text message you
[ __ ] buck-toothed me I can remember
and somehow talked about his teeth and
you were laughing your [ __ ] ass off
I could never recreate that that's why I
had to tap out and you were laughing
your [ __ ] ass off and it was totally
wrong and but then like halfway through
it I started making my point of how I'm
so sick of every time a woman gets the
[ __ ] kicked out of her not every time
but all these women they always get they
always get to show guys in that bad
light of all these guys who beat the
[ __ ] out of their women but they never
show when women [ __ ] over guys ever in
those situations ever like you know the
situations that that I've seen where you
know a friend of mine you know she
slammed the door into him and then just
called the cops and said that he hit her
and they without question arrest him and
then that [ __ ] up his job and now
everybody looks at him like he's a wife
beater he never even did it how come
Oprah never does shows about that that
was our big argument and then she
somehow you know me the way I say [ __ ]
somehow it seemed like I was advocating
that the guy did nothing wrong yes you
know you're not horrible manipul of
preachers but you guys do you definitely
manipulate can I burn a joke here that
that [ __ ] milkshake joke up burnt I
don't have that many listeners I'll
still probably do it on my special I
don't give a [ __ ] so here's a little
tease kind of like when you see a movie
trailer this is kind of a bit I'm doing
on my my special this is what my
girlfriend did one night when I was
driving home this is how much they
manipulate or as I call it lie to get
what they want I was driving home and I
was looking at this [ __ ] there was
this diner and I was driving home and
was late and I was like you know hey you
know I'm gonna stop there I'm gonna get
one of those milkshakes and you're just
like oh my god
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you it's hilarious let's not forget
at the end of the day my job is to late
make those people laugh okay Nia you
don't understand these people work hard
all week
these were Americans they need to come
out and forget about their problems now
whatever I don't have one of my Mel
Blanc I got one [ __ ] voice I do nice
reference I watch cartoons really is
that all it takes to impress you on a
first date that's how you ended up with
me
he knows who does the voice of Bugs
Bunny this guy's a keeper I think this
guy will be able to provide what when I
hooked up we'll save that for another
one but you got it you gotta tell him
huh you had to be impressed with my
skills you see if they just won't give
it up
this guy was [ __ ] [ __ ] blocking me on
an Olympic level he saw who's gonna hook
up he actually tried to split a cab with
you on the way home and I got around
that got around that what happened I
[ __ ] put the cards I went all in
just like World Series of Poker I went
all [ __ ] in she was trying to be all
coy with the little Sammy Davis jr. had
on trying to play all hard to get huh
thinking you were dealing with the
sophomore in [ __ ] college like I
didn't have any [ __ ] lines yeah and
that douchebag kept coming over
cock-blocking me he invited we were all
set I was hanging out I'm at L right now
we were hanging out right mean this
other dude and all of a sudden Nia shows
up right and I can say I can see the
vibe I see the look on her face I know
she wants it now like I just you know
shut up you look great you came up you
had a nice big smile and you're being
flirtatious and I immediately liked you
right so you went to the bathroom you're
with a friend I'm with a friend every
guy knows what you're supposed to do
take that [ __ ] battle-ax out of the
picture okay take one for the team I
can't remember who the [ __ ] you with so
if it's one of your friends I apologize
whatever alright a war memorial so what
is this [ __ ] he goes the opposite
route I said let you went to bathroom I
said listen I'm really doing well with
this girl alright so uh do do like he
was like a chick no I had to be like so
if I'm not paying attention to you
don't get upset this is how like female
this dude was right so I [ __ ] he is
what he ends up doing okay the [ __ ]
guy ends up as we're going to leave you
know I'm thinking okay he's gonna try to
peel off with your girl who's not a
battle-axe and he just goes he invites
another dude over and goes hey you guys
all want to get something to eat
remember and remember and he invited us
over now we're sitting there it's me you
you're not so battle axe friends and
three other [ __ ] [ __ ] are sitting
there and I'm trying to hit on you and
he keeps jumping in and then he goes hey
Nia where do you live oh I live up that
way you want to split a cab remember
that no no you didn't it was over at
that point I I made the move remember
that I said are you least i but before
he [ __ ] said that [ __ ] he was doing
everything I'm anybody to have any cash
and I pulled out my credit card I said
you guys just give me the cash or just
put it on my credit card he goes oh he's
just trying to get the miles remember
that anything could Duke to make me look
like a [ __ ] no no no they gave me
money because I didn't have any cash
this is how I got you which he was
sitting there and I said look are we
least gonna be able to split a cab cuz I
want to go over and have a drink with
you I was like at least be able to split
a cab and then you like why why do you
want to split a cab just putting up the
roadblock and that's when I went all-in
I said cuz I want to kiss you BAM right
and then that was it I didn't [ __ ]
talk to you after that yeah you sat
there with that little stunned look on
your face then what happened we walked
outside damn then then then we walked
out that was the [ __ ] that was one of
the greatest I used to the [ __ ] guys
like that used to always get me I
[ __ ] nailed that stuck the landing
like a male Mary Lou Retton
and you know what the best part was then
I stood up we all a night at that point
I was like [ __ ] it I said what I wanted
to do all this [ __ ] is in I don't need
to talk to her anymore I sort of peeled
off right and then everybody got out to
leave and then you kind of tuck me on
the shoulder said don't worry she could
you say like don't worry we're gonna
split a cab up time and then I'm like oh
this is gonna be great cuz now I mean
and I'm gonna get you get to watch that
little [ __ ] [ __ ] block get his balls
knocked on this on the on the [ __ ]
sidewalk and that's what happened he
came out right clapped his hands member
that came out just like this just like
so you guys ready to go and you were
like yeah actually we're taking a cab
and he was and he was so in [ __ ] block
mode he still didn't have the door break
knew you with it and you were like
listen we're taking a cab and we're
going uptown
you leaned over and you said it and then
that's when he realized that everyone
realized he was a [ __ ] block and douche
and then what did he do he goes oh oh
yeah I mean he just [ __ ] peeled off
huh then what happened my other [ __ ]
classic line boy [ __ ] reeled you in
was a masterpiece [ __ ] masterpiece
then we got in the cab and you said I
thought I thought you were gonna kiss me
and we [ __ ] driving like a maniac and
I go I can't up the cabs jumping around
too much I go I'll kiss you at the first
red light right I was [ __ ] seducing
you and it worked right then we hit the
[ __ ] red light I put one on you BAM
right I couldn't feel your [ __ ] feet
I'm gonna make this story last nine
hours long and then you know what
happened then I sat back and I was
playing mr. [ __ ] cool again like I'm
[ __ ] Walt Frazier in 1972 oh the
callback to the Knicks from an hour ago
right then what happened we stopped
again and I'm sitting there looking out
the window and you go it's another red
light right then we and then and then we
heard that cheesy saxophone from every
[ __ ] sexy movie in the 80s right and
then you were going I'm not going home
with you
I'm not going home with you now whenever
they say that guys you know they're not
going home with you you know that [ __ ]
so what you
have to do is you have to constantly
make them feel like it's safe and
they're in control so before actually
before you said you weren't going home
with me I felt your vibe I knew the deal
so I just said listen I know we're not
going home together but I really am a
good time with you I'd like to have
another drink with you all right I know
a nice bar ba-ba-ba-ba and bam right you
didn't go home with me
we had like [ __ ] eight more drinks
and made out for like the next five
hours in that [ __ ] Hell's Kitchen bar
had a great time there you go so there's
a little story people there's your
little backstory our in one [ __ ]
minutes there you go oh you know I've
got damn it I didn't get to this you
want to you want to hear something
that's gonna make your your [ __ ]
privates crawl sorry I was disgusting
I'm out of funny [ __ ] that's it I'm
overtime right now listen to this guy
you know talking about that dead [ __ ]
down there at the diner that one day
remember that guy go back to Jersey you
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatever the hell he said
so people people were talking about
people were talking about like all the
you know all the [ __ ] and the
confrontations and some people had the
confrontations some people won the
fights some people lost the fight some
people won and got sued other people
walked away and had the [ __ ] anger
like I did so he goes podcast the
bullies point of view this is from the
bully listen to this this is really
interesting bill I just listened to you
last two podcasts and listened to the
stories of these guys that went that
want to beat people when they're bullied
well I think I'm the bully I've got a
hundred stories but I'll give you two
short ones all right fat people bother
me this guy's awesome fat people bother
me smelly people do too combine the two
and give me lots of alcohol and I go off
so I'm down the down the hatch in
Manhattan and fat smelly and fat smelly
guys come in I can't help but tell them
that they are an embarrassment to the
white American race this is what he
becomes like this Aryan psychopath I
guess this isn't funny anymore and he
goes and I'm tired of picking up their
slack now if he's just saying that to be
funny that's [ __ ] hell
Arius for one white person to say that
to another white person did you're an
embarrassment to the white race and I'm
tired of picking up the slap take a
[ __ ] walk at least he goes they don't
say a word
so I slap one right across the face he
goes why I'm not sure what's that movie
you love there with with Christian Bale
American psyche yeah I think this is the
guy I'd love to see his business card he
goes out there's six of them I have four
or five guys with me but they wouldn't
have known that if they wouldn't have
known that and they just walked it they
just walked away out the door probably
to grab some fried food but the point is
they didn't do anything did I feel bad
about it not really it's a pretty funny
story to tell when I'm drunk
oh these stories are hilarious I don't
know if they're true but these are
[ __ ] making me laugh every Milliman
story - so I'm at a bar with a couple of
guys and there's a [ __ ] in it for some
reason I don't notice the little man but
my friends do and the [ __ ] jokes
commence and one of the little men's
friends says something to my friend I
told him to shut the [ __ ] up and poured
my Corona on him he didn't know what to
do about ten minutes later I ordered a
shot and saw some near the bar and toss
that at him - he did nothing why because
98% of the time people people don't know
how to react and clam up it's not just
your listeners of you it's mostly
everyone so don't feel bad about
freezing up and missing your opportunity
and you're right that we don't always
get what we deserve I've been kicked out
of more bars than I can remember I've
had sex with more women than I can
remember and showed all of my friends
pictures of them where did it get me
- a six-figure salary wait a minute you
just want it to be fake you want it to
be fake Nia have you ever seen an
[ __ ] who takes what he wants not
banging the hottest [ __ ] women out
there ever thank you alright let's
continue one more thing
yes oh this will make you feel great all
these all these guys in your podcast he
keep talking about picking up girls are
being scared to talk to them or being
rejects bridge
rejected listen kids I love this he's
talking down to him most of you are in
college or your senior years of high
school [ __ ] go out there and crush
some [ __ ] have trouble talking to girls
here's what you do go to your classes
come back to your dorm room and take a
nap or play Madden or do whatever till
around 1:00 a.m. go get a fake ID or
chalk your ID and move on to the bar
about 1 hour before they close scope out
the action and search for blood be a
shark look for the over inebriated the
overweight the low self-esteem
make it happen he's screaming now make
it happen he's given a little halftime
speech here be blunt ask a girl if you
can grab a little titty stick a hand
down a chick's pants when you're on a
dance floor be aggressive all that [ __ ]
works in the I'm not gonna lie to you
but you just don't [ __ ] do what you
just saw you start doing other areas
that are gateways to that area what if
he turns you on what if he worked out
what if he was a dick and he was
shredded and he just knew it was gonna
be some great [ __ ] stress relieving
[ __ ] Nia you know what you're being
right now right now you're being talk
show audience Nia let me tell you
something anybody puts their hand on my
ass they're getting their ass kicked
[Applause]
you're full of [ __ ] in here if you yeah
all right whatever you're sick I'll let
you go oh and never play up the nice guy
thing
you go in there look like you've done
this a hundred times scared of
performing don't worry they won't
remember it anyways and chances are
they've had worse all right so this
guy's cocky you know I love about him
he's cocky for good reasons and also
cocky for no reasons I mean I know well
he's that he slaps fat people he makes
fun of friends of midgets and he [ __ ]
girls who were too drunk to say no and
now he makes six figures come on you
know he was he was trying to be funny
you know now you got the attitude you
don't care if she comes stays lays
appraised if I see that guy
Damone you know what's funny you know
what's funny about you you already have
that look on your face when you meet a
guy who doesn't give a [ __ ] the same way
I didn't you got that look on your face
that [ __ ] look that let me know that
someday you were gonna be in my bedroom
which you are I just didn't count on me
falling for you that's where I [ __ ] up
that's where you turned the tables on me
huh
cutie pie all right that's it that's it
for the podcast you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
guys I gotta end on a left and sometimes
we don't have a joke you go dirty I'm
teaching these people how to be a
comedian if I was on if they could see
me I just would have made a funny face
that's all my act is I did curse words
and silly faces all right that's the
podcast for this week I apologize to you
[ __ ] for you know taking so
goddamn long but uh I hope you enjoy it
and my next gig is Tempe on the improv
in Tempe Arizona I appreciate it anybody
who can come out please come out to the
show because it's getting close to my
special and tickets will be going on
sale for my special I will have
information next Monday repeat actually
check in on my website billboard.com I
might have a a special announcement this
week and if you want to be in on tickets
as soon as you can sign up for my
mailing list at billboard.com just sign
up under the city that the closest major
city and I'll send out an email right
before I do the announcement that'll be
your little plus for getting on my
mailing list look at that a little
business skill there you like that look
at me all right let's go have some pork
chat what the [ __ ] we eating for dinner
Wow you know feel like cooking anymore I
took you to Sweden in August you drove
in a Corvette and [ __ ] October you're
not gonna cook so what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to eat
you're not sick you've been laughing
your ass off you're coming out of it
you're too silly to be sick huh pasta
that's what I ate when I was single and
I was [ __ ] struggling really can I
eat it on like of the [ __ ] back of a
chair the way I used to I split the
plate right will you say wait I already
told this [ __ ] story all right thank
you everybody have a wonderful week I'll
talk to you next Monday
[Music]
[Applause]